ينضم الينا الان من موسكو كل من العقيد
فيكتور لوفكين محرر شؤون العسكريه في
وكاله تاس الروسيه وايضا معنا منه
رئيسه قسم الدراسات المعهد القومي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه ارحب بضيفي يبدا مع
ضيفه الدكتوره ايرينا اذا حديث من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه الاوكرانيه على تقدم
على اكثر من جبهه واستعاده بلدات في وقت
قصير لكن في نفس الوقت يتم الحديث عن
هامشيه هذه المناطق وهذه البلدات بالتالي
استراتيجيا ما الذي تم تحقيقه من قبل
الاوكراني
يومكم طيب
من المهم ان نقول ان الطرف الروسي للمره
الثانيه المره الاولى في شهر مايو تعلن ان
اوكرانيا وكانها بدات الهجمات المضاده ومن
المفهوم انه هذا غير سليم اذا تحدثنا عن
مساحات
الهجمات العكسيه فهذه المواقع السكانيه
وتحريرها نتحدث عن بعض القرى بالامس
قريتين واليوم قريتين
وبعض الحركات في والتقدمات في اتجاه بخموت
وهذا يحدث يوميا فهذه المساحات
اقل بكثير من ما يجب عليه ان تكون الهجمات
العكسيه اما اذا كنا نتحدث عن مراحل
تحضيريه للهجمات العكسيه فقد يكون هذا
كذالك فالاعمال
كما نراها طوالي
حوالي سنه من هذه الحرب الاعمال
الاوكرانيه منطقيه ومبنيه على اسس لدينا
هيئه الاركان التي لديها تفكير استراتيجي
ويقوم باستهداف مواقع مدروسات اما ما يحدث
هو احد المراحل لتحضير لمواقع اكثر اهميه
واستراتيجيه للعمليات المستقبليه بما فيها
اذا انتبهتم لهذه الهجمات الصغيره وغير
المهمه بقوات قليله من القوات الاوكرانيه
فهي تحدث في الجنوب وتحدث في الشمال فهذه
مساحات واسعه ومسافات واسعه وتحدث ايضا
على حدود لوغان لذلك عن ماذا يتحدث هذا
يتحدث اننا نشكل للطرف الروسي الكثير من
المهمات والصعوبات الهدف الاول لروسيا هي
تحضير للدفاع ولصدر الهجمات العكسيه وهم
لا وهم يحاولون ان يفهموا اين ستكون هذه
الهجمات وهذا يساعد قواتنا ان تكون اسهل
في الحركه نحن نشكل ضغوط وصعوبات على
الكثير من الخطوط في الجبهات انها حوالي
كيلومتر ومن المعروف اننا نقوم بضرب
المواقع
الروسيه بما فيها بالجرد دكتوره فقط لضيق
الوقت وبالتالي هل هناك تخوف لدى
الاوكرانيين من اي رد فعل روسي على هذه
التحركات الاوكرانيه
طب هذا شيء مفهوم نحن نفهم جيدا انه
بالرغم من ان الجيش الروسي
ظهر انه ليس قوي كما كان يعتقد حتى نحن
كنا نعتقد هذا قبل الحرب ولكن
بفضل ان
روسيا منذ 23 سنه
ونظامها الحالي الذي ينهب الدوله يظهر ان
الجيش ايضا سرق واصبح الجيش ضعيف بسبب هذه
الاعمال واصبح اقل تدريبا ونحن نفهم اننا
نحارب ضد روسيا الدوله التي لديها 140
مليون مواطن ولديها قدرات من الاسلحه
عاليه جدا ونحن ننظر للعدو بجده
زياده عن هذا
العدو يحاول بهجمات ارهابيه فيها ما حدث
في المحطه محطه توليد الكهرباء بالطاقه
المائيه عند
الذهاب الى ضيفي لعله يرد على كل هذا
الكلام ويعلق اذا العقيد فيكتور كنت تستمع
لضيفتنا منه تقول بان كل التحركات
الاوكرانيه الحاليه هي بمثابه تحضير لما
هو اهم في مرحله قادمه بالتالي الروس هل
لديهم اي نوع من التخوف من هذه التحركات
على الارض
نحن لا نخشى شيء نحن كنا نتوقع هذه
الهجمات العكسيه المنتظره التي اصبحت اقرب
الى الاسطوره التي الفتها الفتها نظام كيف
ان الهجمات العكسيه تحدث نتيجه هجمات
روسيا لم تهجم على احد نحن متمركزين في
خطوط الدفاع ان اوكرانيا من تقوم بالهجمات
وتفقد الكثير من الجنود ومن الدبابات
الغربيه
وغيرها
الاوكرانيه تسترجع بلدات بالتالي هذا لا
يعني شيئا بالنسبه لموسكو
ماذا يعني استرداد الاراضي انها ليست
اراضيها انها اراضي جمهوريه دانيسك
وجمهوريه الشعبيه اللواتي اصبح جزءا من
روسيا انها تحاول ان تحتل ان تحتل قرى
صغيره في ضواحي دانيسك وتبقي لروسيا
المواقع المرتفعه التي تعتبر اكثر
استراتيجيه ومن حيث نقوم بضربات على
الاراضي والمواقع والجنود الاوكرانيين بما
فيها ايضا هذه مواقع روسيه الحديث عن ان
روسيا فجرت السد هذا كذب جديد من قبل
النظام في كييف الذي فجر هذا السد ومحطه
الكهرباء حتى لا يكون لدى
روسيا فرصه ان يسيطروا على النهر وحتى
يتمكنوا من نقل الق من خرسان الى مناطق
اخرى على سبيل المثال ضخمه التي نسميها
لذلك اوكرانيا تستمر في الكذب على شعبها
وتستمر بالكذب على المجتمع الدولي
فلتكرق في هذا الملف لكن للاسف الوقت قد
نفد اشكرك كنت معنا منا موسكو العقيد
فيكتور لوفكن محرر الشؤون العسكريه في
وكاله الروسيه وكانت معنا ايضا من
الدكتوره ايريناكو رئيسه قسم الدراسات
بالمعهد القومي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
شكرا لكما